vegas's very own ethylene chocolates
turn sporty and they're celebrating the
spring season
with cacti chocolates and champagne
happy 40th anniversary to ethelem
chocolates you guys have been open since
1981 and i hear you're celebrating both
outside
and inside what's going on out here we
are thanks for coming rocky so outside
we are doing our first ever guided
cactus garden tour with our garden
curator
so he will take you through it's on
friday mornings through the end of the
month through
end of may he'll show you the different
plans you'll do a two-piece chocolate
tasting
and then you get to take a piece of a
plant home with you and plant it in your
own garden
that's perfect for the people that love
gardening and florals
but also of course you gotta love
chocolates when you come to ephelips
absolutely and that's why we're here so
the other thing we're doing for the
first time to celebrate is the chocolate
and mimosa tasting
with kovid we had to shut down this room
and thankfully we've been able to open
it over the last couple months
you can see it's all in a very socially
distanced environment
we are really taking care to make sure
everyone feels safe and that there's
room between everyone
um but it's a great time and we're
hoping to say you know sit you down and
do it with you today
you had me at chocolate and mimosas okay
so let's have a seat let's have a seat i
understand this is tammy jo you're our
chocolatier yes my name is tammy jo i'll
be a chocolatier today
okay so what we're going to be doing is
engaging all of your senses
so if you look right over here these are
the senses we're going to completely
engage
sight touch smell taste and sound wow
so which piece did you want to try today
um oh my god they all look
so good but i'm gonna go with this
purple one because it just looks the
most interesting
alrighty so now normally with this piece
i like to give it a little surprise
so take a look at it and try to decipher
what you think it's going to be
smell your chocolate go ahead and remove
your mask down
smell what do you smell smell dark
chocolate yes
absolutely and then i smell a little
fruit
it could be a little fruity and it's a
little messy so be careful for your bite
go ahead and take a bite
oh there we go wow
tasting in this piece oh my gosh so it's
fruity it's tangy
right berries of some sort nice
it's so good all right so now put your
piece down okay
and while that's still kind of melting
on your palette go ahead and pick up
your mimosa you're going to be trying
okay and it has to be the one right in
front of the chocolate
so don't mind if i do our mango mimosa
go ahead and take a sip of that wow
okay so why do these flavors pair well
together the mimosa
peach or mango brings in all those
flavors
so it really brings all the different
flavors from the prickly pear into them
this is delicious i'm having so much fun
and obviously this is a 45 minute
experience but we
narrowed it down to about 2 minutes and
30 seconds so tell everybody how people
can
make a reservation absolutely just go to
ethylm.com and look at experiences and
you can book online it's every weekend
through the end of may of course in
limited space so book soon
and for more information you can visit
ethelim.com